One topic you'll hear quite a lot of in
information technology is automation and
scripting. There are a lot of different
ways to automate processes and we have a
number of different scripting
technologies available to us. But you
have to make sure that you're using the
right script for the right purpose. The
type of scripting language that you
choose may be based on the application
you're running or the task that you're
performing or it might be specific to an
operating system and there might be a
limited number of options available in
that OS. This means that you'll probably
learn a number of different scripting
languages so you can automate regardless
of what task you're performing.
If you're running an automated task in
Windows, you could be running a batch
file. You'll know this because the name
of the file has aBABBAT file extension.
This is something that you'll run at the
command line inside of Windows, but the
use of batch files goes back to DOSs and
OS2. This means that you have decades of
documentation that can help you build a
batch file to automate processes inside
of your Windows system.
If you're a Windows system
administrator, then you're probably not
using a batch file, but instead you're
using PowerShell. This is a command line
that's a bit of an upgrade from the
batch file days and it provides a number
of additional capabilities, especially
for system administrators. PowerShell
scripts commonly have a PS1 file
extension. And if you're running Windows
10 or Windows 11, you can simply click
the button to install PowerShell if it's
not installed already. PowerShell
scripts can take advantage of built-in
functions referred to as commandlets.
They allow you to extend the
functionality of PowerShell to be able
to access an operating system directly
or be able to change things in the
operating system that you normally
wouldn't have access to from a standard
command line and a batch file. You can
even build these PowerShell scripts into
standalone executables and simply
distribute that executable to whoever
needs to run that script. So, if you're
doing any type of Windows administration
or you need to administer a large Active
Directory infrastructure, you want to
become very familiar with Windows
PowerShell.
Windows also includes a generalpurpose
scripting language that you can run
outside of the command line. This is the
Microsoft Visual Basic Scripting
Edition. So, you can perform functions
such as a back-end web server script.
You can script on the Windows desktop
itself, but you commonly see these VB
scripts inside of Microsoft Office
applications. These Visual Basic scripts
are often identified with a file
extension of VBS.
As we mentioned earlier, if you're
scripting at the Windows command prompt,
you're using a batch file. But if you're
scripting inside of Linux, you're using
a shell script. Shell scripts are the
process used inside of Unix and Linux to
be able to automate inside of a Linux
shell. Shell scripts don't require a
specific extension type, but we commonly
put ash on the end of the file so that
we can easily identify them. If you look
at the script itself, you'll notice that
the first two characters of the script
are a hash and an exclamation mark. This
is known as a shebang or a hashbang and
it designates that everything following
that information is a Unix or Linux
shell script.
Another script that often works behind
the scenes in our browser is JavaScript.
These usually have ajs file extension
and they're used for interactivity in
our browser screens. So if you go to a
website and you click something on the
screen and notice that there's some
interactivity that's all probably being
created through the use of JavaScript.
It's also important to keep in mind that
there is a difference between JavaScript
and Java. JavaScript is the scripting
language that we use inside of our
browsers. But Java is a programming
language that you would use to create
applications. These have a very
different use, a different
implementation and they were created by
completely different organizations. So,
if you're working with JavaScript, keep
in mind that this is not related at all
to Java.
Cloud-based services have changed the
way that we think about automation. This
is because cloud-based services are not
about a specific operating system or a
specific work environment. Instead, we'd
like to have scripting and automation
done in the cloud that can be applied
towards any operating system. That was
part of the reason behind the success of
Python. Python is a generalpurpose
scripting language that works across
many different operating systems and
provides flexibility whether you're in
Windows, Mac OS, or Linux. You'll often
see Python scripts labeled with AP py
file extension. Python has a great deal
of support in the industry and has
become very popular as a way to script
across many different operating systems
without having to change a lot of
information inside the script. Here's a
simple interactive shell script. It
starts with the hashbang right at the
beginning and it runs as a shell script.
You can see the /bin /sh. It has a
variable called input string that is
being set to hello. And then there is a
loop as part of the shell script. This
has an echo which means it's putting
information on the screen that says
please type something in or type by to
quit. And then it waits for you to input
information into this script. When you
hit enter, it echoes information to the
screen that says you typed. And then
there's a variable that repeats the
information that you typed into the
system. It will continue through this
loop until you put in the string by. And
at that point, it will say that you
typed by and it will then quit the loop.
This is a very simple example of being
able to automate a process within a
script. And as you become more
comfortable with the scripting
languages, you'll start creating longer
and more complex scripts so that you can
automate the things that normally you
would have done manually.